did not see that coming Disney
princesses are the most beautiful kind
and sweet women we know but it is hard
to believe that they didn't even try to
be a little wild when they were
teenagers this is why three artists
reimagined what they would look like in
the modern world make sure you watch
this video Until the End to see what
Pocahontas has been up to if you love
Disney princesses as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you 10 Disney princesses
reimagined as modern day bad girls Ariel
The Little Mermaid has always been a
little Rebel when she lived under the
sea she used to be fascinated by the
world of humans she collected things
that used to belong to them and loved to
visit a shipwreck with her friend
flounder Ariel even dared to go to the
surface of the ocean to meet her friend
Scuttle a seagull who didn't really know
the human culture but Ariel had to keep
that passion secret from the other
mermaids in the Kingdom of Atlantica her
father King Triton had said previously
that the contact between myrrh people
and humans was forbidden that didn't
keep The Little Mermaid from realizing
her dreams and becoming a human to meet
the love of her life her father would
probably never approve that she
exchanged her voice for legs but Ariel
did it anyway she's the kind of girl who
doesn't listen to anyone when she knows
what she wants and it seems like now
that she is a full-time human Ariel
found another passion as NADA street art
reimagined her she now wants to be part
of a new world a world of basketball
players and thinks she will know
everything about them by playing this
video game she looks so cool that we
think these athletes won't mind talking
to her but if she wants to be part of
their world she will have to prove that
she can really use her new pair of legs
Belle this young lady was such a nice
and smart girl that we would never see
her breaking the rules yes she was a
little bit strange but in the best way
villagers were surprised to see a young
woman reading books when most people
didn't even know the alphabet at that
time but Belle didn't even care because
she thought that fiction was more
interesting than reality however there
was one time she didn't listen to her
father and this is the only time he
wished she did when Maurice was thrown
Behind Bars Bell decided to rescue him
she finally found him in BEAST's castle
and asked if she could take his place
her father absolutely didn't want her to
do that but she forced him to accept and
this is how the young woman was trapped
in the castle of the monster everyone
was happy in the end and Bell even chose
to stay in the castle with her prince
but what if she had really been a bad
girl instead of being a hero when you
see how not a street art reimagined her
you know that it is impossible for
anyone to think that this girl is
strange she is cooler than ever maybe
this is what happens when you marry a
handsome rich man in the 21st century
Tiana
this young lady didn't have time to
break the rules in any way since she was
a child she dreamed of opening a
restaurant with her father and when he
passed away it wasn't time for her to do
all the things she ever wanted to do
instead she wanted to make him proud and
work hard to start her own business this
is why instead of partying Tiana was
working as a waitress in a restaurant
she barely had time to fully enjoy life
but she thought that she would be doing
this later then one day a frog offered
her all the money she needed to make her
dream come true Tiana finally accepted
to kiss that random boy and she
immediately regretted it that crazy
adventure ended up being one of the best
things that ever happened in her life
but we think that what she likes most is
having the chance to work hard again in
her restaurant however if the princess
doesn't have time to act like a bad girl
she at least has time to look like a bad
girl as she was reimagined on Disney
hardcore with her black dress her cool
piercings and all the tattoos she
doesn't look like a princess like any
other with naveen's playful personality
we think that they will make the perfect
couple
Elsa the princess had always been
different but she thought that it was a
bad thing Elsa was embracing her powers
as a kid but after hurting her little
sister she thought that it was better to
stay away from others this is why
instead of being true to who she is she
decided to lock herself in her room Anna
was probably the most disappointed to
have lost her sister during all these
years but all kids have to Rebel at some
point in their lives and Elsa did it a
little too late after being crowned
queen her sister made her a little angry
and this is when she revealed her power
to everyone not able to face this
situation Elsa simply ran away leaving
her responsibilities behind and giving
herself the chance to do whatever she
wants Elsa finally came back to
Arendelle to save everyone but
everything would have been way less
complicated if it happened during her
teenage years when her parents were
there to help her but what would she
look like at that time if she had the
chance to do anything she wants when you
see how this artist reimagined her on
Disney hardcore you can easily
understand that Elsa needed to let go of
a lot of things she doesn't look like a
nice girl anymore and we love to see
that she finally dares to be herself
Jasmine
she was probably one of the luckiest
princesses on our list but that doesn't
mean that she was happy Jasmine had
everything she ever wanted in her Palace
except one thing freedom and it just
became worse when she understood that
she would soon be forced to marry
someone even if she hadn't found the
love of her life yet this is why she
decided to leave everything behind and
Escape her Palace it wasn't the best
decision as she didn't know anything
about the outside world but she was
lucky to be saved by Aladdin who always
does his best to help the people in need
and he also gave her what she needed the
most the freedom to fly away on a magic
carpet and discover A Whole New World
Jasmine finally broke the rules a little
to marry a thief and this is how they
lived happily ever after but what if
Jasmine decided to be a bad girl even
though she has to stay in the palace
here's how NADA street art reimagined
her her father probably isn't happy to
see that his daughter is smoking and
wearing a really provocative outfit but
at least she's at home and that's all
that matters will Aladdin be even more
intimidated by her new look only the
future will tell what will happen
between these two
Snow White
as the youngest Disney Princess Snow
White was barely a teenager when her
life changed forever she could have been
a spoiled kid being born in a royal
family when her parents passed away her
evil stepmother decided that this child
shouldn't be so lucky after all this is
why she decided to dress her in rags and
force her to work as a servant cleaning
the floors and washing the dishes every
day the best thing she could ever do was
dreaming but things changed when the
evil queen decided to get rid of her and
Snow White had to run away in the forest
while she lived with the Seven Dwarfs
the Only Rule she ever broke was
trusting a stranger who gave her an
apple and it ended up being one of the
worst mistakes she ever made because she
passed away before being saved by a
prince but what if she were a little
luckier when she decided to be a bad
girl let's take a look at how not a
street art reimagined her Snow White is
still the fairest of them all but this
time she clearly knows it this is why
she keeps taking selfies in her bedroom
we think that her parents might still be
alive in the modern world because we
can't imagine her stepmother giving her
an iPhone even though she will probably
give her another Apple product a
poisoned one
Cinderella when you work as a servant
you don't have a lot of time to Rebel
that didn't keep Cinderella from trying
to go to the ball her friends the mice
made her a dress and she was ready to
party unfortunately her evil stepsisters
and stepmother quickly made sure that
she couldn't even be dreaming anymore
her fairy godmother saw that it was
unfair and this is why she decided to
give the young woman everything she
needed to go to the ball and meet the
love of her life Cinderella was a
teenager like any other after all she
ran away from her home without asking
her mother's permission and decided to
party all night with a boy however there
is one rule that shouldn't be broken and
it's not just coming back home after
midnight it's talking to strangers if
they had known each other's names they
wouldn't be strangers anymore and it
would have been way easier to find each
other but would Prince Charming
recognize Cinderella with her new look
as reimagined by Ashi monster with her
pink hair piercing and choker necklace
she finally has the chance to look like
the bad girl she always wanted to be
it's no surprise that the prince had to
make her try on a shoe to see if it fits
the size of her foot is the only thing
that didn't change Rapunzel
trapped in a tower for almost 18 years
it's no surprise that Rapunzel would
like to become a bad girl but during all
her teenage years she had always been
Mommy's little girl Rapunzel woke up at
7am to clean her room she loved reading
and she always baked some cookies that's
the kind of daughter that most parents
want but most importantly she never cut
her long blonde hair to make sure that
her mother could use its magic power to
stay young forever we can't blame the
princess for being too nice and always
obeying her rules the only reason why
she didn't Escape was that her mother
lied to her about the outside world but
as soon as she got a chance to be free
and jumped out of the window she never
looked back being a bad girl was the
best thing to do after all now let's see
what Rapunzel would look like if she was
not a nice girl anymore as reimagined on
Disney hardcore instead of painting her
walls her body is covered with tattoos
she also dyed her hair white which
probably took days and was really
expensive we bet that this modern day
Rapunzel still lives with her parents
because Mother Gothel would never let
her do that to her magical hair
Pocahontas
this young Native American was lucky to
have all the freedom that she wanted
when she was a teenager at any time of
the day she could just walk away into
the forest and discover the beauty of
nature with her friends Mikko and flit
unfortunately growing up means more
responsibilities and Pocahontas feared
to have to marry kokom a brave Warrior
who was too serious for her
free-spirited personality it's also at
that time the English came to America
and the young woman couldn't keep
herself from breaking the rules curious
to learn more about the world of these
white men she met John Smith and they
quickly became friends this relationship
is what saved everyone at the end but
the two lovers were finally separated
and it is better this way so we have
seen a young Pocahontas who grew up in
nature but what if she was born at the
beginning of the 21st century we don't
recognize this Native American Girl
anymore now that we see how NADA street
art reimagined her she is living in a
big city and loves Starbucks and macaron
and when it comes to exploring the world
all she needs is to turn to her computer
we bet that Pocahontas is talking to
cute boys all around the world online
it's always great to discover different
cultures
Moana
this young woman always wanted to break
the rules since she was a child she was
fascinated by the sea but unfortunately
her parents wouldn't let her go anywhere
near water that didn't stop Moana from
one day going on a big adventure it
wasn't easy the first time and we
thought that we would never see her on a
boat again but Moana didn't give up she
found out that she was the chosen one
and knew that she was the only one who
could save her tribe it wasn't only
about reuniting a mystical Relic with a
goddess but also finding out who she
truly was Moana almost gave up begging
the ocean to take the heart and choose
someone else but she finally understood
that there was a reason why she was
chosen and she was finally the one who
saved everyone with the help of demigod
Maui being a teenager is another big
Challenge and some young women face it
by being a bad girl that's the case for
this modern day Moana as NADA street art
reimagined her this time her parents
won't stop her from going to the beach
but from wearing something that might be
a little too mature for her age if you
could choose one princess who could be a
part of a remake in the 21st century who
would it be don't be try to tell us what
you think in the comments section Down
Below in Disney movies we get to see our
favorite princesses finally find their
happily ever after but not much is known
about their lives once these movies come
to an end aren't you curious to see what
Elsa Tiana Ariel and the rest of the
princesses are up to now well we found
photos from the next stage of their
lives motherhood you won't believe what
their kids look like especially Merida's
bundles of Joy if you're new to our
Channel make sure to subscribe and give
us a big thumbs up today we'll be
showing you the adorable photos of 10
Disney princesses reimagined as parents
Elsa
Queen Elsa doesn't ride off into the
sunset with her handsome king once
Frozen comes to an end however that
doesn't mean this Disney character lived
the rest of her royal life all alone
thankfully an artist by the name of
Isaiah Stevens has given us a glimpse
into Elsa's Life as a mother and we must
say she's handling motherhood perfectly
in this photo Elsa is spending some
equality time with her little baby boy
the look in her eyes is priceless she's
beaming with joy and so much pride
motherhood really completes her don't
you think and her beautiful baby boy has
all of Elsa's features including her big
blue eyes and her wispy blonde hair but
not only that it appears that Elsa's son
was also born with the unique ability to
make ice and snow just check out the
little snow flurries coming from his
tiny little hand it just warms our
hearts to see Elsa all grown up and
embracing this new stage of her life and
looking at this photo really makes us
wonder who her King is wouldn't it be
awesome if Disney released a new movie
that's focused on Elsa's Life as a wife
and mom we think so
Ariel
Disney fans were already introduced to
Ariel's daughter Melody in the film The
Little Mermaid 2 return to the Sea but
judging by these artists Renditions our
favorite mermaid and Prince Eric decided
to expand their family after Ariel gave
birth to Melody and now they're a family
of four in this photo the artist Linnea
asberg created a stunning family
portrait of Ariel Eric Melody and baby
pontus
just like most of the character names in
The Little Mermaid pontus was named
after the pre-olympian sea god in Greek
mythology they all look so happy and
content as they hang around in the sea
but if you think this picture is
breathtaking you ain't seen nothing yet
we have another photo of Ariel and
pontus that really tug at your
heartstrings artist Isaiah Stevens
created this candid moment between Ariel
and her little baby boy in the photo the
mermaid is feeding her royal Prince but
it looks like he's more focused on
having a food fight instead thankfully
Ariel is able to keep her composure and
embrace the joys of motherhood no matter
how messy things may get her little boy
looks like a handful doesn't he we
wonder where he gets his playful nature
from Cinderella
Cinderella's Early Childhood was
heartbreaking she was forced to be
raised by her evil stepmother and she
spent most of her childhood cleaning and
scrubbing floors instead of being a real
kid but we always knew deep down in our
hearts that Cinderella would grow up to
be an amazing mother we know she would
never dream of treating her own child in
such a cruel and unfair way in the film
she's always so kind and patient despite
her Rocky upbringing she would never
even harm a fly or a mouse for that
matter we're curious to see what her
life is like after marrying the love of
her life and having a baby how about you
well the artist Linnea has answered our
wishes once again in this photo
Cinderella her prince and their son are
having a bit of fun outside the palace
he's the spinning image of his father
don't you think what do you think they
named their little boy well according to
the artist his name is Jacob he was
named after one of the co-auth authors
of the original Cinderella fairy tale
we're so happy the princess is now able
to live a calm and peaceful life
surrounded by nothing but love
Mulan
it looks like Mulan is finally ready to
step away from the warrior life she's
leaving the battling behind to embrace a
brand new adventure she and Shang had a
bumpy relationship in the film Mulan 2
but it looks like they're back on track
they're now happier than ever bringing
peace to the two Chinese kingdoms these
days the couple is embarking on a
journey to become parents in this photo
from the artist Isaiah it looks like
Mulan is in the final stages of her
pregnancy and just take a look at her
face she's absolutely glowing she looks
so calm and relaxed we definitely think
she's ready for all that will come along
with motherhood it also helps that Shang
is there with her every step of the way
he looks so proud that the love of his
life will be giving birth to their mini
Warrior if they have a boy we expect
he'll be just as great of a leader as
his dad but if they have a girl we're
pretty sure she'll be bold confident and
brave just like Mulan Parenthood will be
one of the hardest battles of their
lives but we don't have any doubt that
these two lovebirds will be amazing
parents
Merida
Merida is the only Disney princess who
doesn't have any sisters but we're sure
she didn't mind one bit growing up she
was raised with her triplet Brothers
Harris Hubert and Hamish these three
little boys were always full of mischief
like the time they were caught fiddling
with the trophies in fergus's Trophy
Room Merida was probably looking forward
to the day when she was an adult and
living out on her own without her
annoying little brothers pestering her
but triplets obviously run in Merida's
family so it's really no surprise that
now she's all grown up she's the mother
of triplets too this drawing was created
by an artist named chabe Escalante it
looks like motherhood is really getting
the best of Merida doesn't it she's
potty training her triplets and instead
of using the potty they decided to
scribble their self-portraits on the
wall instead these little girls
definitely take after their uncles but
the best part about Merida having three
brothers is they give her a little break
by stepping in and taking turns
babysitting the little girls we hope
Parenthood gets easier for Merida as her
triplets get a bit older but for now
they're definitely giving her a hard
time
Jasmine
next up we have Princess Jasmine artist
Isaiah once again put his imagination to
the test by creating an amazing
reimagined photo in the film Jasmine
fell head over heels for Aladdin who's
far from being a royal despite their two
different upbringings Aladdin and
Jasmine fell in love and now they're
about to be parents since they come from
two walks of life we think their
personalities will mix together
perfectly their child is bound to have
all of their amazing personality traits
from Jasmine's free spiritedness to
Aladdin's kind-hearted nature in this
photo of the loving couple Jasmine looks
as beautiful as ever she has ditched her
midriff bearing outfits for a beautiful
tank top and a flowing skirt but she's
still looking as stylish as ever with
her matching headband and her Flawless
makeup and just look at the excitement
on Aladdin's face he can't wait to be a
dad and hold his new baby in his arms
aside from having two awesome parents
their new baby will also have a friend
in jail Jasmine's pet tiger Raja we're
sure he will be fiercely protective of
the family's new bundle of joy
Tiana
with two caring and supportive parents
in her life it's no wonder Tiana grew up
wanting to be an amazing parent too the
main character and the Princess and the
Frog had all the traits of a good mother
she was hard working an awesome cook and
very kind to everyone she came in
contact with we always wondered what
Tiana and Prince naveen's lives would be
like after their Disney fairy tale came
to an end thankfully we don't have to
wonder any longer the artist Linnea has
created a beautiful portrait of Tiana
and her family are you ready to see it
well here it is how cute does the couple
look as they play with their beautiful
baby girl in the bayou they're all
decked out in their all green outfits
and they're looking as happy as ever
their baby girl also appears to be
wearing a miniature size version of
Tiana's iconic green ball gown now
that's what we call twinning according
to the artist the baby girl's name is
Stella which means star and Stella is
absolutely the star of this family and
the apple of her parents eye
Rapunzel in the movie Tangled Rapunzel
is forced to live her life Behind the
Walls of the Tower and she's convinced
that only bad things happen in the
outside world in the film Rapunzel sang
the song when Will My Life Begin well
the answer is now long gone are the days
when the princess was bored of her dull
life as depicted by the artist Isaiah
Rapunzel is now an adult and living life
with her new family we already saw Elsa
beaming with pride at her little boy and
Mulan glowing in her last stages of
pregnancy however Rapunzel is
experiencing the Messier side of
motherhood in this image she's changing
her baby's diaper while her hubby Flynn
Rider ducks for cover while Rapunzel is
handling this typical mommy duty like a
champ Flynn is doing his best to mask
the stench with a gas mask strapped to
his face
well he better get used to the smell of
dirty diapers because it looks like
Rapunzel is enjoying every minute with
her new baby
we wouldn't be surprised if the couple
decided to add on to their family by
having another and another and another
with her natural healing powers her baby
doesn't have to worry about any Cuts or
bruises while learning how to ride a
bike when they get older and the child
doesn't have to worry about making new
friends anytime soon they instantly
gained a BFF through Rapunzel's closest
friend Pascal
Pocahontas
Pocahontas's life Journey was far from
over when the Disney film came to an end
in 1998 Disney released a sequel called
Pocahontas II journey to a new world and
it depicted an unfortunate ending to The
Princess and John Smith's romance in the
movie John Smith went missing Pocahontas
was upset but she was forced to move on
with her life she set out on a voyage to
England to meet with King James and
that's where she met a man named John
Ralph later on in the film John Smith is
finally located and he begs for
Pocahontas to run away with him but as
the saying goes it was too little too
late Pocahontas fell in love with John
Rolfe and they moved to Jamestown to
start their lives together now that
we've got that out of the way we have a
photo of Pocahontas that we can't wait
to show you are you ready to see what
she looks like as a mom well take a look
at her now isn't this photo absolutely
beautiful the new mom is catching some
disease while her baby naps in her arms
they look so calm and peaceful together
where sheer Pocahontas is a wonderful
mommy and if she ever needs any
parenting advice or guidance she can
always turn to grandmother willow
Snow White we couldn't make this video
without including one of the most
popular princesses of them all Snow
White she may be one of the youngest
Disney princesses in the lineup but
she's wise Beyond her years
Snow White has a calm and quiet
personality that makes her a favorite
amongst her furry friends and the Seven
Dwarfs we're positive that not only
would she make a good wife to the prince
but we know she'd make a great mother
too the artist Linnea asberg decided to
completely recreate Snow White and turn
her into a dotting Mom are you ready to
see what her life is like now well here
she is in this picture the princess is
holding on tight to her baby while her
prince looks at them both with so much
love in his eyes but take a look at
their adorable little girl she looks
like Snow White's identical twin she has
the same jet black hair the same wide
and expressive eyes and identical Rosy
Cheeks according to the artist the
baby's name is Ada which means kind and
we're sure she'll grow up to be just as
kind as her mom too now that baby Ada
has arrived into the world she has
probably already been greeted by all of
Snow White's friends including the Seven
Dwarfs when the prince and princess are
in need of some alone time we are sure
the divorce wouldn't mind entertaining
the baby for a few hours now that's a
clever movie idea we'd love to see on
the big screen the lives of our favorite
Disney Princesses changed forever when
they were teenagers but we were curious
to know what happened when they were
kids and toddlers before meeting their
prince charming this is why we imagine
what their lives would be like if this
is your first time visiting our Channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 Disney princesses
reimagined as kids snow white she's the
first Disney princess and also the
youngest and only 14 years years old her
childhood is not too far behind her Snow
White was born to a royal family
unfortunately she didn't have the chance
to live the life of a princess her
mother passed away after birth only
living long enough to give her that
beautiful name then her father remarried
a cold-hearted Queen only to join Snow
White's mother shortly after the evil
queen cared about nothing other than
being the fairest of them all and when
she saw that the little girl was
becoming more beautiful every day she
became jealous this is why she dressed
the child at rags and forced her to work
as a maid so when we saw how an artist
reimagined Snow White wearing that
beautiful dress we understand why the
evil queen was afraid of the competition
the princess is prettier than ever and
we think that she should already be the
fairest of them all even at a very young
age she is also wearing the Tiara that
she deserves and seems to be going
outside for a picnic instead of doing
chores maybe this is what Snow White
would look like if she had been raised
by her parents but everything happens
for a reason so this life of misery
might just be what she had to go through
to meet The Prince and live happily ever
after Cinderella here is another
princess who was treated like a servant
this time until she was 19 years old
Cinderella was born to wealthy parents
who loved her and lived in a beautiful
castle her life changed when her mother
passed away and her father remarried
another woman to make sure her daughter
had a mother figure in her life the
young girl would have been happier with
a single father because her stepmother
turned out to be a horrible woman when
her father passed away Cinderella was
left alone this is when she realized how
cruel she could be lady Tremaine spoiled
her two daughters Anastasia and Rosella
and forced the young orphan to work as a
slave no matter what Cinderella had the
strength to stay sweet humble and kind
but what if this stepmother decided to
treat her like her own daughter instead
this is how the artist reimagined her
she doesn't need the help of mice or a
fairy godmother anymore the young girl
is already wearing a gorgeous dress that
she received for her birthday and she's
also wearing a tiara herself because
even if she's not a princess yet she
thinks that she deserves to be treated
like one and she's right every child
should be the most important thing in
the world to their parents
if you want to watch just one more video
the premium is the platform where you
should go get early access to videos
from the things the taco the trendy the
richest and many other great channels in
one place with ad-free browsing click
this link to sign up for the premium and
get ready to binge watch videos from
your favorite channels
foreign
her story is similar to what Snow White
lived falling in a deep sleep and being
saved by the kiss of a prince but these
two princesses had really different
childhoods a king and a queen had been
blessed by a beautiful blonde daughter
people from all around the kingdom came
to celebrate her birth three of them
were fairies giving her the gift of
Beauty and the gift of singing but
before the third fairy could use her
magic wand Maleficent appeared and
cursed the young princess her life would
end when she would prick her finger on a
spinning wheel the third fairy used the
last gift to give Aurora the chance to
be saved by the prince to make sure that
she was safe the young blonde girl was
raised by the three fairies until she
was 16 years old and as we can see from
this picture they took good care of her
young Aurora is full of energy she is
not the kind of kid who will be able to
sleep too early as we can see the
fairies finally decided that she would
be wearing a pink dress but we bet that
they will change their mind soon and
argue to make the princess laugh this
little family is proof that even if your
parents don't have the chance to see you
grow up what matters most is that you
can stay with people who love you Ariel
this beautiful sea creature lived a
childhood unlike any other until she
decided to live on land at the age of
16. The Little Mermaid was the seventh
and youngest daughter of King Triton
ruler of Atlantica she seemed to have
all the things she needed but this
wasn't enough for her all her life she
collected Little Treasures that belong
to humans and dreamed of one day walking
on the land she spent her day exploring
the sea looking for another object that
sunk under the water unfortunately this
admiration for the human world was not
appreciated so she had to keep it secret
from other sea creatures Sebastian and
Flounder were the only ones who knew
about this and as we can see they have
been friends for a very long time the
yellow and blue fish was already by her
side when she was a little mermaid Ariel
seems to be a funny kid we bet that she
spends all day discovering new places
and finding objects that will help her
understand our world her father is
probably nervous every time she leaves
because he doesn't know when she'll come
back and we understand why he is she's
the kind of girl who can exchange her
voice for a pair of legs and almost
disappear for ever for a stranger we
better watch this little girl or teenage
Ariel will get into trouble really
quickly Belle the young woman is one of
the lucky princesses who had the chance
to live a beautiful child until her life
changed at age 17. her mother came from
a wealthy family but passed away shortly
after the birth of her daughter and
Maurice was left with the most precious
thing you could ever find Belle she had
the chance to be raised by a loving
father and she probably had a lot of
unusual toys to play with when we see
all the crazy things he can create but
what she loved most was reading as soon
as she learned how to read Belle
couldn't keep herself from opening a new
book and being transported into a new
universe in this picture you can see
Belle wearing her most beautiful dress
this is not the girl we saw at the
beginning of the movie but the one that
Maurice saw in her his princess she
means the world to him little bell is
not interested in any boy because her
father is the most important thing in
her life he is the one who encourages
her to follow her dreams and he knows
that women were born to be more than
just a pretty face they are both a
little weird but also very smart and
this is why they have an amazing
relationship Jasmine she seems to be one
of the most fortunate princesses on our
list but her life was not as beautiful
as it seems a lad in the street urchin
was envious of her luxurious life but
there was one thing missing for her to
be happy as the daughter of the sultan
Jasmine had to live in the palace she
didn't have the right to leave her royal
home or meet other people her mother
passed away years ago and the only
friend that she was left with was her
pet tiger Raja the princess thought it
was a gift from her mother as she used
to tell her stories of the tiger star
jasmine wanted to see the world and
experience life outside so we think it
was probably difficult for her to live
on her own as a child and this artist
reimagined her as a dreamer who can't
wait to go outside even if her father
gives her all the things she needs this
is not what little Jasmine wants she
just wants to do what all the other kids
do but no matter what we know that her
father the sultan loves her very much he
just doesn't have the time to show it
the only thing missing is the Magic in
her eyes and Aladdin will one day make
her discover A Whole New World Mulan
this girl is not a princess like any
other actually she isn't even one but
she has all the quality she needs to
rule the world and become a queen even
if she's just 16 years old born and
raised in China Mulan had to respect a
lot of tradition she was told that the
girls must be pretty be graceful and
know how to serve tea they are not
supposed to fight they said her family
wanted to turn her into the perfect
housewife waiting for the day she would
meet her future husband but this is not
what clumsy and free spirited Mulan
wanted when we see how Irene Martini
reimagined her we know that her dreams
actually are bigger than that this girl
knows that being a kid is about having
fun and experimenting and she doesn't
want to play with dolls she wants to
play outside even if it means getting
dirty in the mud and ruining her
beautiful dress she is not shy to say
that she is one of the boys anyway she
never thought that wearing girls clothes
was comfortable as a kid she is not shy
to be herself but she could get prepared
for all the challenges waiting for her
in the future daring is her biggest
strength so make sure that you don't
stand in the way of this stubborn kid
who knows what she wants and how to get
it Tiana the more we watch Disney
Princess movies the more we wanted to
hear about their childhoods this is why
Tiana was one of the first young women
that we really got the chance to see as
a kid with her best friend Charlotte she
listened to the classic tale of a
princess kiss seen a frog and she was
disgusting Tiana was not interested in
boys but in learning new things with her
father James is the one who taught her
how to cook while they were making their
favorite recipe they dreamed of opening
a restaurant together but he reminded
her that she had to work hard and when
he passed away 19 year old Tiana never
let go of her dream this princess
reimagined by an artist doesn't know yet
what it's like to have tons of
responsibilities this little dreamer
still has a lot of energy wishing can
only get her halfway to her dream and
this is what she's working on right now
little Tiana doesn't know what's going
to happen to her father now but he will
be forever a source of inspiration for
her Merida we know what it's like to
become a teenager and get more distant
with our parents Merida is no exception
when she was a kid she had a close
relationship with her father and mother
always ready to have fun she would play
hide and seek with the woman who raised
her but what she loved most was archery
we wouldn't let a child play with a bow
and arrow but this one is extremely
skilled the redhead was also really
curious and naive believing the myths
and legends of her kingdom little did
she know she would soon be become the
hero of her own fairy tale story the
little Merida reimagined by Irene
Martini is still very affectionate she
loves to cuddle with her bear which
could represent the relationship she had
with her mother at the time this little
girl is not really stubborn yet because
her parents let her do whatever she
wants she doesn't have to think about
looking like a proper lady and
everything is perfect like that we hope
she enjoys her childhoods as much as she
can because she will soon have to face
the responsibilities of being an adult
we think that 16 year old Merida we know
is still close to her inner child
because she acts like one and there's
nothing wrong with that don't you think
these little humans often look much
happier than grown-ups Rapunzel we won't
forget about the princess who had a
really unusual childhood before her
birth her mother was sick and had to eat
a magic Golden Flower with healing
properties this is how Rapunzel got her
powers but Mother Gothel wanted it to be
hers when she saw she couldn't just cut
the blonde hair she decided to take the
baby instead this evil witch locked the
child in a tower until her 16th birthday
but even when she was on her own
Rapunzel was never alone she had her
friend Pascal to make her laugh and her
creativity to transform her room into
another Universe we can see her energy
shine when we take a look at the
princess reimagined by an artist she
learned to be happy with the little
things and can turn anything into a
funny activity her hair is not long
enough for her to jump out of the tower
but she is preparing herself for this
crazy adventure by dreaming out loud
painting and reading are great ways to
escape and this time this is certainly
something we can relate to is there any
princess who looks like you as a kid
don't be shy to tell us in the comment
section below we'd love to hear what you
think Disney princesses have become
iconic throughout the ages from their
facial features to their hair their
looks are pretty unique but what if
their faces and clothes were different
would you still be able to tell them
apart now is the time to see these
characters as you may have never seen
them before just wait until you see the
Disney princesses reimagined as
dinosaurs if you're new to our Channel
don't forget to click the Subscribe
button and give our video a big thumbs
up get ready to be stunned because today
we are going to show you 15 Disney
princesses reimagined by amazing artists
abstract princesses this section is
dedicated to the abstract Collective of
artists who have taken unique liberties
with their reinterpretations of Disney
Princesses one artist shows just the
hair outline of several Disney
princesses dressed in suits from Quentin
Tarantino's Reservoir Dogs this one is
of dung beetles playing a top Disney
Princesses heads and this one presents
them as a series of dryer lint take a
look at this hysterical mustache series
and this wacky inflatable whaling arms
one our favorite though is this
wrestling match of Cinderella flying
through the air when it comes to the
weird and wacky of Disney reimagining
these images definitely take the cake
gender swapped princesses princesses
aren't the only ones with distinct
Styles in Disney films the gentleman of
these films have a distinct style all
their own what would you think if the
princesses and princes swapped outfits a
Japanese digital artist created some
amazing conceptual designs depicting
just that he says he loves Disney and
draws these for fun and respect of The
Originals he seeks no profit how cool
are these outfits of our favorite girls
The Princess and the Frog's Tiana looks
super cute in naveen's clothes Bell and
Ariel look very Dapper and Eric and
Beast clothes Esmeralda Pocahontas and
Mulan are looking mighty Fierce and
ready for battle in their outfits it
looks like these princesses can rock
just about any outfit anyway all we can
say is thank you for these creations
princesses as men so we had some fun
looking at Disney Princesses dressing in
their princess outfits and we totally
loved them so what would our favorite
princesses look like if they were men
one extremely talented artist named
sakimichan accomplished just that when
she gender swapped the Disney Princesses
here is a male version of Elsa from
Frozen and we totally love this gender
swapped Belle and beast beast is looking
very pretty Pocahontas and Ariel are
looking extremely handsome and how cute
are their companions Mikko and Flounder
the details in color in zakimi's work
are flawless and amazing we definitely
want to see more of Chan's work how cool
would it be to do the films over with
these characters real size princesses
Disney princesses are world renowned for
their breathtaking Beauty sweeping
through the streets singing and twirling
and gowns but our Disney Princesses slim
figures realistic or is it a distorted
vision of what a woman is to look like
this Tumblr artist who goes by the name
nameless doll wanted to combat the
unrealistic proportions particularly the
tiny waistlines that the Disney
princesses have the nameless doll's
version of Belle has more realistic
proportions striking isn't it here is
Frozen's Anna before and after this is
Rapunzel from Tangled before and here
she is after for years fans have called
on Disney to bring a more realistic
Disney princess to the screen after
seeing these maybe they will take the
hint their princesses might be Fuller
but gorgeous nonetheless Rebel
princesses the princesses of Disney have
a reputation of being sweet and innocent
with not a mean bone in their body sure
they have SASS and can throw a mean
punch but they aren't full-fledged
troublemakers the princess's innocence
and naivety of the world tend to lead
them to fall into trouble then sometimes
end up in jail captured by evil villains
or Worse almost dead thankfully the
prince saved Snow White with that kiss
but what would these princesses look
like if they were more rebellious thanks
to Evie art we don't have to wonder
check out Gothic Bell Glam Cinder
hipster Jasmine pinup snow rebellious
Tink and hipster Ariel most of these
princesses are unrecognizable but that
doesn't stop them from looking good Star
Wars princesses with new Star Wars films
coming out the fandom is growing even
more we love Star Wars and we love
Disney Princesses so why not combine the
two talented artist Ralph ceveelius did
just that take a look at Jedi Ariel and
her double lightsabers Elsa as a Sith
ice queen and Snow White is a Sith Lord
are amazing we bet that they would rule
the galaxy except when Jedi Ariel comes
around with her Padawan Rapunzel her
lightsaber is part of her long hair how
creative is Ralph Aurora is perfect as
Frozen Carbonite Han Solo she is
sleeping beauty in the most Star Wars
way possible with Star Wars now being
owned by Disney we wonder if this mashup
will ever become a reality bearded
princesses this next reimagining series
might just be the most weirdly
satisfying and unsettling of them all
ill illustrator Adam Ellis developed an
entire series of Disney princesses with
plush beards they were created in honor
of movember where men don't shave for
the entire month of November to raise
awareness for Men's Health Adam's images
are just as fun as the titles he has for
them such as this Disney film entitled
the bearded mermaid look at Ariel with
those flowing red locks on her chin or
Princess mustacherella talking with her
fairy godmother Alice in beard Land
Beauty and the beard and beer to
hauntest just take a look at Sleeping
Beauty mulong beard The Princess and the
beard and beard Lantus The Lost Empire
and who could forget the all-time
classic beard Latin featuring princess
jasbeard we can tell Adam had a lot of
fun creating these presidential
princesses the princesses of Disney are
far removed from the political landscape
of the world they live in their castles
palaces and even Under the Sea they long
for living extravagant dreamy lives with
no desires of standing in front of a
Podium they don't want to give
long-winded speeches full of never to be
filled promise is for the people however
in 2016 MTV decided to bring these two
worlds crashing into one another MTV
commissioned artist Annabelle Coe to
combine her love of Disney characters
with 2016 presidential hopefuls and the
resulting portraits are wildly
hysterical Carly fiorina is Princess
Jasmine Mike Huckabee as Tiana Jeb Bush
as Ariel and Ted Cruz as Snow White
Bernie Sanders as human aerial Hillary
Clinton as Cinderella and Donald Trump
as grumpy Sleeping Beauty these images
can't be unseen but we love how
hilarious they are makeup artist gone
Rogue growing up it's hard to escape
never seeing a Disney film once you've
seen one you typically fall into the
love it or leave it category this next
artist is a prime example except their
artistic interpretation exceeds the
realm of pencil to paper Richard Shafer
is a 22 year old freelance makeup artist
who transforms himself into princesses
from his favorite Disney movies this guy
has some serious skills I mean just look
at all these pictures that L Pocahontas
Snow White Cinderella and Ariel the list
goes on and on Richard says dressing up
has helped him to feel more confident as
a person with over 250 followers on
Instagram it sure shows reinvented
princesses for those of you who spend
hours every day surfing through the
endless array of Instagram feeds you
have probably already come across the
work of Isabelle Staub she is a
freelance illustrator who blew up
Instagram with crisp reimaginings of the
classic Disney Princesses she says each
of these images took her around 8 to 12
hours to recreate the lady's fresh bold
looks the entire process is done in
Corel Painter and a few last touch-ups
done with Photoshop here is Esmerelda
from The Hunchback of Notre Dame now we
know she's not technically a princess
but with this makeover she is looking
absolutely Royal how about adorable
Belle with those cheeks Jasmine's
highlighting Contour are positively
radiant and how about Ariel check out
those pouty lips and shiny hair and how
about those wide blue eyes what a
reimagining realistic princesses just
when you thought something reimagined
countless different ways couldn't be
reinvented anymore Along Comes Jerka
vitenin he is a 27 year old graphic
artist based in Melbourne Australia His
stunning interpretations created a
firestorm over the Internet he turned
our favorite Disney Princesses into real
people so if you've ever wondered what
they would look like as real life people
this is for you take a look at a
real-life portrait of Princess Anna
complete with adorable freckles this one
of Rapunzel pulling on her hair or
Merida from Brave she seems so real with
her curls down to the freckles and
wrinkles in the dress it's easy to
forget that these are not real
photographs but he doesn't just stop at
princesses take a look at Eric from The
Little Mermaid Prince Hans and Kristoff
of Frozen an adorable Prince Naveen if
only they were real
mommy princesses after our favorite
princesses got there happily ever Afters
we wish we could still see more of their
lives what happens when their dreams
come true do they start families one
artist takes us through the Journey of
motherhood with our favorite princesses
artist Kristen Reeves was inspired to
reimagine her favorite Disney princesses
as mothers when she was pregnant with
her own son check out Belle's sweet
Embrace with her sweet baby Ariel looks
so happy holding her tiny daughter
Jasmine's adorable baby looks quite
content being in her arms how adorable
are the pigtails on Rapunzel's daughter
we love these sweet moments of
motherhood the soft more subdued colors
are totally working for these tender
moments it looks like motherhood suits
these princesses very well we also love
to see that our princesses have equally
adorable babies velasa princesses with
the release of the new Jurassic world
film our love of dinosaurs has been
re-sparked our favorite dinosaurs in the
film The Velociraptors artist Laura
Cooper decided that she would
commemorate the release of Jurassic
World by reimagining princesses as
Raptors she says that a princess is many
things and a raptor is one of them she
took this concept literally and gave us
this series of hysterical raptors look
at Anna and Elsa Raptors we love the
Merida Raptor whose face is covered with
red curly hair Bell Raptor still looks
lovely in her yellow ball gown as does
Tiana Raptor and how about Raptor
Pocahontas and that flowing hair these
Raptors are not only clever but also
hilarious we hope Laura continues making
all future Disney characters into hungry
Raptors Rock princesses through the ages
of Disney films princesses have played a
part in every child's development
growing up one way or another there
really is no escaping The Vortex which
is Walt Disney for this very reason a
lot of people in the world actually
despise princesses they feel princesses
are bad role models and contain no
substance as they're usually trapped by
the bad guy this concept of no substance
was taken quite literally by artist
Kevin bulk he created a series of
princesses as rocks you heard that right
rocks he took one of the most
recognizable features of these
princesses their hair and put it on top
of rocks we can still recognize them
just by their signature look this
concept is hysterical as it is ironic
clever one Kevin clever punk rock
princesses Disney princesses are known
for being songbirds as well as being
beautiful but what would happen if we
gave our favorite princesses a taste of
some punk rock and heavy metal music
what would their songs sound like what
would they look like a couple of artists
have reimagined the princesses as
princesses of hunk Rock and Metal Check
out Ariel's bright pink hair dark makeup
and Tattoos we are totally jealous of
Belle's awesome two-toned blue hair how
cute does Rapunzel look with her long
pink hair the dark makeup and long
lashes around Anna's eyes make them look
even bigger this reimagining is a huge
departure from the usual Disney princess
but it is so much fun to see we aren't
too sure Disney is quite ready for some
heavy metal ballads just yet we can
never get enough of Disney Princesses
and once again talented artists
reimagined our favorite characters
Miriam safdar and Andrew Pina recreated
pictures of the princesses and another
characters as Japanese cartoons and we
have to admit that they look even more
beautiful and funnier than the originals
just wait until you see what Aurora
looks like when she is sleeping if this
is your first time visiting our Channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 15 Disney princesses
reimagined as anime
Rapunzel
the princess spent 18 years alone in a
tower trapped by a witch and that's a
shame for everyone who didn't get a
chance to see how beautiful and kind the
young girl was that is until Flynn Ryder
entered her room and gave her the
opportunity to discover the outside
world but because we could never get
enough of her Miriam safdar imagined her
as an anime character and the princess
is even more beautiful now that we can
see more details she still has the long
blonde hair and traditional German
purple dress but this time her beautiful
green eyes are shinier and we even see
her freckles and by the look of her face
she is just about to escape her Tower
and discover a Wonderful World do you
wish you could see anime Rapunzel going
on an Avenger
Cinderella
in this rags to riches story we had the
chance to see a poor servants become the
most beautiful princess in the Kingdom
with the help of a fairy godmother who
dressed her in a beautiful dress the
prince immediately fell in love with her
so to make sure the princess will be
happy ever after Miriam safdar recreated
the young woman wearing her most
beautiful outfit as an anime character
her eyes are bright blue and her hair is
a little Messier but she is even more
beautiful with all these added details
she looks even more grown up now she is
19 years old after all with this more
realistic and updated look the young
woman will be ready for prom in 2017. do
you think she'd be crowned prom queen no
matter what in a fairy tale or real life
Cinderella would deserve a crown on her
head
Alice
she might not be a princess but she
looks just like one and this time she
didn't have to wait for a prince to go
on a wonderful Adventure the daydreaming
girl followed a rabbit and ended up in
another magical world and as you can see
in this picture from Miriam safdar it
seems like the little girl never left
Wonderland she is still holding the
White Rabbit in her hands but this time
he looks much more realistic did she
imagine all this or was this world real
no matter what no one could ever doubt
that Alice is really beautiful with her
blonde hair they blue eyes and little
blue dress she looks just like a doll
and she can even be just as small as
this toy when she drinks a potion from a
bottle do you think that Alice should
become an official Disney princess
Jasmine
the Arabian princess is truly a wish
come true we understand why Aladdin asks
for Genie's help to win her heart and in
fact she was so beautiful that they had
to make sure the street Archer looked
better than the other princes too they
made him older took off his shirt and
made him more confident so do you want
to see the look of the princess who
inspired this Prince here is Jasmine
reimagined by Miriam safdar
she looks so good as an anime character
the color she wears are even brighter
and her hair and eyes are shinier
Jasmine is just as precious as a diamond
but this artist is not the only one who
imagined this princess as anime just
look at this artwork from Andrew Pena
Jasmine now has round her eyes a tiny
nose and brighter hair and by the look
on her face the young princess looks
really happy to see Aladdin
Ariel
[Music]
our favorite little mermaid made a man
fall in love with her when she couldn't
even talk with only her beauty to seduce
a prince this girl must be very pretty
and that's exactly how Miriam safdar
represented her her long red hair looks
so good that she must have brushed them
for hours with a fork how can they be so
shiny after years swimming in the sea
and we totally understand why Eric would
want to kiss the girl with those sweet
lips and if you want to see more or the
mermaid reimagined as anime here's
another creation from Andrew Pena her
look is much more expressive and instead
of red lipstick she is now wearing a
dark eyeliner we would love to know
where she buys her makeup because we
have never seen anything so waterproof
Mulan
Mulan didn't want to marry a man or
become a housewife instead she became a
man and joined the army this is why it
is surprising to see that Miriam safdar
recreated her as a feminine character
instead of her old father's armor Mulan
is now wearing a pink and purple kimono
dress as when she was prepping for the
Matchmaker she even wears a flower on
her head even though we know that this
ornament is too fragile for her great
adventure she looks like she is ready to
meet her future husband but we think
that it won't last long soon Mulan will
take the place of her father in the Army
and pretend to be a man to become a
great warrior of China take off that
kimono a woman needs to wear something
more comfortable if she wants to save
her country
Tiana
the girl didn't mind being the most
beautiful of them all she just wanted to
work hard and have enough money to
realize her dream but isn't this
ambition what makes her look even better
as a young waitress as a princess and
even as a frog no man can resist her
Miriam safdar imagined her at her best
when she is dressed as a princess green
suits her perfectly as a woman or as an
amphibian but we have to admit that we
still love seeing her working as a
waitress too here's how Andrew Pena
reimagined her her eyes are bigger and
we love that beautiful smile Tiana's
hair is a little Messier but we don't
mind we know that what matters is not
what's on her head for what's in it
let's just hope she will be the one
serving our favorite meal every day and
soon it will be in her own restaurant
Kira
even though she is a princess of
Atlantis most people forget about this
Disney character but this time we pay
homage to this Warrior who saved her
City and became a queen now let's take a
look at this artwork from Miriam safdar
to see if you remember her the princess
is even more beautiful with all these
details in her hair she still wears a
blue pendant around her neck and blew
makeup on her face but this time we can
see her in a brighter light to really
appreciate her beauty the creators
didn't want her to be a damsel in
distress like the other princesses they
wanted her to be a warrior like no other
and as you can see from her look all
these artists succeeded in making her a
unique character do you think Kitty
deserves to be an official Disney
princess don't be shy to tell us what
you think in the comments down below
Pocahontas
the Native American princess tat John
Smith to just look around him to realize
how beautiful nature is but little did
she know the most gorgeous thing he
could see was Pocahontas standing right
in front of him once again Miriam safdar
made the princess look even more
beautiful than she is in the original
movie we love those eyes and the high
cheekbones and the character also looks
more mature than what we used to see all
the little details let us discover even
more of her beauty but if you want to
see Pocahontas in the funniest way just
look at this drawing from Andrew Pena
her eyes are way bigger than they were
before and Pocahontas now has Rosy
Cheeks is she shy to see John Smith by
the way she looks at him it just seems
like this man probably said something
that didn't please her once again
Elsa
how could we forget Queen Elsa we will
never let it go this is probably one of
the best Disney Princess movies after
hiding her power for years and trapping
her kingdom in a Perpetual winter she
discovered that all she needed was a
sister to warm her heart and as you can
see from this picture from Miriam safdar
she received so much love from her
sister that she became a summer Queen we
know one little snowman who will be
happy to hear about this with a green
dress covered with pink flowers the
people around her can finally enjoy a
beautiful summer day and we can forget
about her sister Anna she now looks like
the princess of spring with all these
flowers on her dress no matter what we
know that these sisters will stay
together during their Four Seasons the
warmth and the cold never bothered them
anyway
Merida
the redhead didn't need a man to tell
her she is beautiful she already knew
she was without making any effort and
what made her prettier is that she
didn't even care about that Merida had
better things to do than trying to
please anyone as you can see in this
drawing from Miriam safdar the princess
is more beautiful than ever she kept her
natural looks with no makeup wild hair
and tons of Freckles but this time don't
you think she looks older than she is in
the original film instead of being 16
she looks like she could be in her 20s
after all you should marry a man when
you're too young but she doesn't care
about them anyway her heart belongs to
herself and no one will ever keep this
brave princess from being who she wants
to be
Tinkerbell
the little fairy might not be a princess
but she's still one of our favorite
Disney characters following Peter Pan
everywhere her greatest strength was
making everyone smile and you have to
admit that you want to see what she
looks like as an anime anyway so let's
see how Miriam safdar imagined her she
kept her bubbly personality but she
looks even prettier when we can take a
closer look at her with all these
details we can truly believe that magic
exists and it is hidden in the forest in
Neverland how could we explain why
Tinkerbell is so gorgeous otherwise
looking so good must be one of her
secret powers don't forget to say that
you believe that fairies exist today we
want this beautiful creature and her
friends to live forever we believe in
fairies
Snow White
mirror mirror on the wall who is the
fairest one of all it's Snow White of
course but not the one we saw in the
original movie The Princess as anime
looks even better just take a look at
this artwork from Miriam safdar the
beautiful teenager looks even younger
now after all she is supposed to be 14
and this time she really looks like she
is Snow White seems even more innocent
without makeup and with her wavy hair
but please someone tell her not to eat
the apple in her hand and as you can see
in this picture from Andrew Pena someone
just told her that the fruit was
dangerous and she looks more shocked
than surprised who could have done that
to her if she thinks about the fact that
her stepmother wanted a hunter to steal
her heart she's probably one of the
primary suspects Aurora
if there's one girl who looks gorgeous
when she's sleeping it's Aurora she
never expected that she would fall
asleep for days when she found a
spinning wheel but she managed to look
so beautiful lying in bed anyway she
looks so great that a prince couldn't
resist the temptation of kissing her and
as you can see in this picture from
Miriam safdar we would love to fall in
love with her too just look at these
gorgeous blonde locks and that pretty
face the artist even dared to imagine
her with purple eyes this characteristic
is so rare just as this princess's
Beauty but it's time to have a little
more fun just watch what Andrew Pena
thought she would look like as an anime
character sleeping we're not sure if
Prince Philip would like to kiss her
right now but but she would definitely
make him smile now this is what a real
woman would look like if she spent the
whole day sleeping
Belle
with the name like that we could expect
the princess to be the most beautiful of
them all and she truly is not only on
the outside but also on the inside No
Other Woman could have taken the time to
make the Beast a better man and turn him
into a prince charming but could you
believe that she could be even prettier
than she already is just take a look at
this picture from Miriam safdar she is
ready for the ball and once the prince
sees her there would be no going back he
won't be able to keep himself from
falling in love with her but now let's
take a look at another version of Belle
from Andrew Pena this time she didn't
take the time to do her hair or do her
makeup and she doesn't even care the
Beast will love her as she is or he
won't love her at all
did you know that 84 of My Little Pony
fans are male and we bet a lot of them
also love Disney if you love The Two
Worlds you're in for a real treat
because we're about to show you the most
amazing illustrations we have ever seen
Rapunzel is really rocking the My Little
Pony look don't forget to subscribe to
the things and give this video a thumbs
up today we're checking out 10 Disney
princesses reimagined as My Little Pony
Princess Jasmine
My Little Pony is a popular show for
kids and teenagers this resulted in a
lot of interesting illustrations that
mixed the world of Disney with My Little
Pony characters let's start with
arguably one of the most beautiful
Disney Princesses ever Princess Jasmine
is one of those characters you just
can't help to love She's incredibly
Progressive stubborn feisty and has a
heart of gold so what would happen if we
mixed Princess Jasmine's look with a My
Little Pony character here's a very
fabulous looking Princess Jasmine as My
Little Pony she still has that bling on
her and we love her long dark hair
Princess Jasmine would perfectly fit in
the magical pony world as you know each
Pony represents a powerful element that
relates to friendship with that in mind
which element do you think Princess
Jasmine would represent would it be
honesty or would it be confidence we're
sure she'd have a lot to bring to the My
Little Pony story and she'd certainly
add a sarcastic tone to normal
conversations that's what you'd get from
princess Jasmine but our next Disney
princess would bring slightly different
values do you think the ponies would
react well to a frog that would turn
back into a Disney princess inspired
Pony sounds like our next character
might be quite a handful
Princess Tiana
Princess Tiana is incredibly loyal and
she knows she has to work hard to
realize her dreams and never give up she
looks sweet on the outside but don't
underestimate princess Tiana's values
and spirit now imagine what would
Princess Tiana look like if she became a
My Little Pony character she'd add a
whole lot of fabulous to the pony crew
and we'd love to see this look on the
show this illustration belongs to a
deviantART user inkling97 and it is
gorgeous this version of Princess Tiana
has merged Well with My Little Pony and
we love her green dress the necklace and
her dark hair do you think the lack of
opposable thumbs would get in the way of
Tiana's dreams of running a restaurant
knowing this headstrong princess she'd
probably figure out how to make it all
work with her new features as a pony
wouldn't you love to see that story
Princess Tiana looking like a pony
trying to run a restaurant as if being a
frog wasn't difficult enough did you
ever notice that we've never seen
Tiana's hair being loose she always had
it tied back for the entire Princess and
the Frog movie and we love that the
artist let her hair down for this My
Little Pony look speaking of hair wait
until you see Brave and Rapunzel's look
in a few minutes
Belle another outspoken princess on our
list is Belle Belle is compassionate and
kind to everyone how many Disney
princesses do you know that are
passionate bookworms we can probably
count them on one hand so it's no wonder
why Belle is such a popular character
this deviantART artist did an amazing
job putting Belle into the world of My
Little Pony this Pony looks focused
reading her book but yet we can see that
this is Belle based on her brown hair
and her blue bow do you see the detail
on the book it looks like Belle is
reading her own Beauty and the Beast
story we can imagine she'd get along
with many of the Pony characters
including Twilight Sparkle who's also
quite a bookworm we bet the two would
have a thing or two to talk about the
Disney fan base still can't figure out
what Belle's actual favorite book is
remember the scene where she talks about
the far-off places daring sword fights
magic spells and a prince in Disguise
some think she's talking about Aladdin
While others just believe she is
foreshadowing what will happen to her
life story well there's a spot for Belle
on the My Little Pony show and we'd love
to see it all happen
Ariel
you'd better get ready because the
Little Mermaid just became the Little
Pony and we love this look why do these
ponies look so fabulous in any situation
you could put them under water and
they'd still manage to rock the look we
are in love with Ariel disguised as a
character from My Little Pony her red
hair is looking even more gorgeous if
that's even possible Ponies as mermaids
is such a popular concept you can find
several online dress-up games and see
what Ariel would look like as a pony on
your own but let's go back to this the
Little Pony character for a moment we'd
love to see what Sebastian and Flounder
would look like as cartoon ponies did
you know that the color of Ariel's thin
was specifically Blended by the team
behind the movie to complement the
existing colors of the sea nothing quite
like it was ever created before and this
particular color is named Ariel after
The Little Mermaid we'd love to see more
sea creatures in the original My Little
Pony show and it looks like having a
mermaid would be a perfect fit which
values do you think Ariel would bring to
the table we bet they would be different
from our next Disney princess and we can
only hope these friendly ponies know how
to walk on ice
Elsa
okay Elsa it's time to let it go and
become a part of a brand new world do
you ever wonder what Elsa would look
like if she became a My Little Pony
character she's a feisty one much
feistier than Princess Jasmine or Belle
but Elsa's love for her family is what
she would bring to the elements of
friendship check out this glittery
version of Elsa as a charming and feisty
looking Pony we love the gorgeous braid
and the sparkles on her ponytail did you
know that Elsa was originally supposed
to be a villain the co-directors of the
movie explained that Elsa was supposed
to be a villain and they changed her
character when they heard Let It Go they
also highlighted the importance of Anna
and Elsa having an emotional bond this
Bond helped shape the movie Into The
Frozen you know today so if there's
anything else I could bring in the My
Little Pony world its family values and
the importance of having an emotional
bond with the person you love and of
course we can't forget her amazing
singing voice which belongs to The
Talented Idina Menzel it's safe to say
Elsa would be able to out sing
practically any My Little Pony character
and we'd love to see it happen
Snow White
let's just jump right into this
illustration because it's just so darn
cute while other My Little Pony
illustrations so far all show the
typical long-haired look Snow White's
version is sporting cool short hair the
red bow is still there and the artist
added a long blonde braid to the
ponytail but what we love are the three
cute red apples next to the ponytail
Snow White is one of the youngest Disney
Princesses out there but at just 14 she
is one of the kindest and loving
princesses out there who else could do
such an amazing job at befriending
everyone they meet speaking of Snow
White did you know Walt Disney was just
a year older than the Disney Princess
herself when he decided to retell the
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs Story
the movie was released in 1937 and it
became an instant success we love the
original look of Snow White but did you
know that the dwarf's eyebrows were
modeled by Walt Disney's eyebrows on the
other hand Snow White's Charming look
was based on a young dancer Marge
Champion do you think Marge would
approve of this version of Snow White as
a My Little Pony character
Cinderella
it looks like the Fairy Godmother casted
another Bibbidi-Bobbidi-Boo spell and
turned Cinderella into a My Little Pony
princess we're not sure why but this
looks suits Cinderella just as much as
her original look Cinderella is one of
those classic stories that will never go
out of style it brings important life
lessons of always being kind no matter
what believing in yourself and taking
chances this is exactly what Cinderella
would bring to the My Little Pony show
and she'd look fabulous doing it this
Pony is definitely rocking the
Cinderella hairstyle and we'd love to
see more details in this transformation
did you know that Cinderella was the
second most successful Disney movie at
the time and the first to have its songs
copyrighted and published we'd love to
see what some of the other characters
like Gus Gus would look like as My
Little Pony characters do you notice the
detail on Cinderella's picture this Pony
is even wearing a glass slipper it would
be very interesting to see how that
would play out in the actual show with
the My Little Pony version of Cinderella
still be as graceful or what her glass
slippers give her even more trouble
she's not the only one with a special
feature just wait until you see our next
character Mulan
is Mulan your favorite Disney princess
wait until you see what we have in store
for you this version of Mulan as a My
Little Pony character might just be the
best one we've seen yet Mulan is known
as being completely independent and
witty in our eyes she's one of a unique
Disney Princesses out there this
illustration belongs to a deviantART
artist Benny Bing who created one of the
most amazing My Little Pony characters
she looks like she's ready to take a
stance and protect the people she loves
the most which element of friendship do
you think Mulan would bring in the
series would it be selfless or perhaps
being determined and going after what
you want we'd love to see these Two
Worlds Mix this My Little Pony character
is different than the others we love
that the artist highlighted mulan's
facial features and gave a flower in her
hair unlike Tiana or Belle this
illustration comes with very little
detail but we can still easily see more
characteristics shining through Mulan is
also one of the most popular people's
choices when it comes to tattoos but we
somehow can't imagine anyone picking a
tattoo of Mulan as My Little Pony
Merida
we all know Mulan is a fierce character
but is she fiercer than this
orange-haired Disney princess who
doesn't need a man to have a popular
story we love Merida's unique look but
we also love this unique illustration of
our favorite character from Brave as a
character from My Little Pony if Mulan
is a free-spirited Disney princess we
think that Merida is a whole nother
level of free-spirited her story is
inspiring for anyone who is looking for
a strong female Disney character as
their role model this version of Merida
was created by a deviantART user Apostle
bird who did an amazing job at showing
Merida as a very Fierce Pony as usual
her hair is absolutely out of control
did you know that Merida's hair was
quite a problem for the animators behind
the movie Merida was the first Disney
princess that was able to show off her
beautiful hair this was a result of long
quest to find that perfect animation
software that would enable the creators
to create slightly more realistic
characters and it worked even as a My
Little Pony character Merida looks ready
to fight for her rights speaking of hair
there's only one Disney character whose
hair is so fascinating we can't help but
wonder how did Disney manage to create
such an awesome look
Rapunzel
if there's a Disney princess that would
perfectly fit in the world of My Little
Pony it's Rapunzel the slightly naive
but headstrong 18 year old is one of the
quirkiest princesses out there don't
forget she uses a frying pan to fight
off anyone that stands in her way the
biggest friendship element she would
bring to the My Little Pony crew is love
and we agree because we love her magical
pony look did you know that the animator
behind Tangled hired his daughter who
then created Rapunzel's room he
explained that when she was younger she
was already interested in painting by
the Time Tangled was in production his
daughter was so good he ended up just
hiring her to create the look of
Rapunzel's room but it's not just
Rapunzel's room that catches your eye as
you're watching the movie her 70-foot
long hair is fascinating while Merida's
hair was developed using a new animation
software the animators behind Rapunzel's
we'll use the old techniques but it's
safe to say that the talented team
managed to do the impossible to create
Rapunzel's long hair the team used
70-foot long cloth and dangled it out of
the balcony to see how it would move we
can imagine why this My Little Pony
Rapunzel character doesn't have her
signature long-haired look but that
doesn't mean we don't love it
which was your favorite Disney princess
My Little Pony character let us know in
the comments and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up